guys like you
don't believe someone like me that says
that when i dress up i dress up because
i want to look good i want to look in
the mirror and i want to be like jed you
look great today and end of story i'm
not trying to impress men i'm not
playing that game i'm not interested in
that game i never was interested in that
game i had men coming after me because i
didn't play that game because i wasn't
out to impress them i had guys 10 years
later jeremy is a running joke in my
house my husband's always like did you
get a text from that guy you went out on
two dates with in 2001 and sometimes the
answer is yes
because i didn't play that game i wasn't
out to impress them and you guys can
sense that and feel it off of a woman
when we're not playing the desperate
game or we're not trying to get your
cash or we're not trying to
we exist so what i'm saying is don't let
that corrupt you so much that you forget
that there are women out there who are
bad ass who are confident who don't play
that game and who aren't dressing up for
you they're dressing up for me if you
happen to like it great that's great but
it's not for you it's for me okay that's
what i'm saying more power to you i want
you to do it just adam's like what did i
just walk into i'm totally cool with
that but yeah i don't i don't
i don't think
that most women when they dress up
and
you're five five all of a sudden you're
five eight
you had a b cup now you got a d cup
that's the problem your lips are are
small now they're big your hair's this
long now it's this long you're doing all
these things as a woman
because you want to feel good no i think
oh [ __ ] no i think you want to compete
in the sexual marketplace that's right
and get a guy and by the way
the
top 80 percent of women 80 i'm not
talking about
homeless raggedy [ __ ]
most women 80 percent want
the 20 of men so if you go on dating
apps most guys 50 50. hot not hot not
hot hot not guys 50 50. women
no no no no no no oh he looks nice oh
he's a doctor yes okay no no no that's
true women are way more selective and
great quality versus a man wants
quantity well she's not looking for
quality she's looking for cash well
that's quality that's what's deemed high
value man that's not a high value man
well that doesn't make a high value she
says i want a guy to live in a mansion
to drive a business take her advice i'm
talking about that listen don't women
don't take her advice men don't take her
you want to know call her out you want
to know about a high high value man ask
a high value woman i'll tell you
straight up that does not money does not
make a high value man what makes a high
value man is someone who's responsible
someone who's committed someone who you
can count on someone who's reliable
someone who's motivated the amount of
cash in your pocket has very little to
do with what character you have
telling you you can tell me you can find
me the most
reliable dependable compassionate
nice guy and if he's making 35 grand a
year
move on to the next guy no girl is going
to deal with a broke guy
it's not going to happen i have dated
many men that didn't have a lot of money
in their pockets many times and that's
why you're the [ __ ] boss no i'm not
going to probably run the show with
those guys
i don't know jeremy no but i guarantee
you you run the show you know what you
hear what he's saying right now i
guarantee the show i guarantee you on
the show in your household you see what
you're doing though what you're not
listening to the high value woman tell
you what a high-value woman who told you
that you're a high-value woman i did i
don't need you to tell me that's why i'm
a high-value woman honey there you go
you see what i'm saying yes but most
women they're trying to land don't say
most women though because you have to
acknowledge that we exist and there's
more of us than you realize because
you're used to seeing some girl be like
look to be clear
let me just
i don't have
any hobbies
okay i worry
boom thank you i work
i make good money i spend a lot of time
doing content with valuetainment and in
my off days i kick it with my boys and i
kick it with girls in south beach that's
what i do
i don't collect trading cards i don't
maybe you should because i don't i don't
i don't do parasailing i don't have any
expensive hobbies i don't have any weird
little quirks i'm a people person i like
hanging out with yeah i mean i'm yeah i
can be weird sometimes but the point is
i interact with a lot of women i love
women they're probably the best thing on
the planet right no doubt i'm not
disrespecting women hopefully you're not
hanging out with women like that they're
out there though i avoid them i give
them a little heisman stiff arm and i
keep it moving but
guys will find her attractive and get
caught up in like charlotte's web over
there i'm sure the idiot men they're
they're out there
yeah but if you're a guy can i tell you
something though you talk about money a
lot
the women who go after men i'm not
talking about women who find guys that
they ha that they like they're really
into and that guy happens to have money
that can happen too right you find a guy
you click with him you mesh on many
levels they happen to be rich great it's
an added bonus that works what i'm
talking about is women who actually go
for a man based on their finances you
know what happens in those relationships
in
five to ten years i will guarantee five
years let's make five i guarantee you
those women are either divorced
they've left they've taken what they can
get they're out because they went for
him for the wrong reasons or they are
now still married and sleeping with the
guy who works down the block at the bar
and plays guitar and sings to them at
night and makes them feel wanted desired
appreciated so what i'm saying is be the
type of man you want to like shoot for
success financial independence is a
great thing right it's respectful it's
ambitious it's fantastic i appreciate it
in men i appreciate it in women shoot
for that
but that doesn't make you a man what
makes you a man is your character don't
forget that because we see the high
value women of the world we see that
i i agree with what you're saying i feel
like
money will only get you in the door so
to speak and it may not get you in in
some doors right true that but it is a
major quality to get you in the
conversation
with a woman where you live how much
money you make your car all that stuff
see that doesn't impress me at all that
wouldn't impress me at all maybe i
listen maybe i'm the only one
maybe i'm the exception it doesn't it
just doesn't you know what like when i
when i think of men i'm married now so
this is i'm trying to get back into my
single head jeremy i apologize but i
have to do it sorry jeremy we're going
there i have to it's mine right now what
really appeals to me in men is like a
man who can take care of business like
who can
run his household who can defend himself
who can like you know
who can cook who can you know make some
cash who who can go build a construction
site go build something go show me
something you did with your bare hands
you crawl out from underneath a car that
you just fixed
you know that's me so to me all that i
don't care how much money you have in
the bank i would listen i care that you
can put a roof over your head greasy car
mechanic who makes
35 grand a year he comes home with his
dirty fingernails and he will cook you a
salmon fillet well i mean why isn't that
going to cook every night but it's quite
tasty i thought jeremy works in like
tech he
tech not really tech okay but he's not
getting dirty and doing manly well he
does he does he like he's like very into
like everything in my apartment like he
had a hang he had to do like we do we
can't we live in an apartment but he
does have that that rawness to him but
all i'm saying is like
men oftentimes have this perception of
like money money money and i think what
that means is for a lot of women for me
anyway it's not about cash but it's
about like i like an ambitious man
i like a man who wants to take care of
his family who wants to put a roof over
the head if you have kids who wants to
take care of business money is part of
that let me tell you you don't have to
be a zillionaire and be flashing me your
cash and your rolex and all your
[ __ ] i don't care about any of that
you just hit the work because i've
like
google it i've interviewed thousands of
women especially stuff on the men on the
street and even on my show on the size
cast i asked women like what are the
most important qualities you're looking
for a man and you just kind of named a
few of them number one
is confidence women like a confident man
is that fair to say
well yeah i mean i'm a little weird on
that because i do like i do kind of like
the peter parker because you're the
alpha there it is yeah but you're not
motivated
you're not most women
i do like number two i do ambitious yep
they want a man who's ambitious the
problem with ambition
is that's great up to a certain point
how many 80 year olds are made no money
you're like i'm gonna make it one of
these days it's like no [ __ ] at
some point that ambition needs to turn
into money yeah okay i agree with you so
ambition's cool when you're young and
you're hungry and okay like i'm gonna
bet on this guy i don't know he's like
he's 26 but i think he's got something
to go in it but like by the time you're
36 or 46 if you're still broke but
you're ambitious yeah at what point does
one be like yeah i don't know about this
yeah so ambition needs to turn into some
sort of success yeah and once you start
having success
confidence comes with success like i've
always been pretty
confident like i already was like yeah
like i've always done well in
school and girls and sports or whatever
but when i started having money
and i was like all right wherever i go
whoever i meet i'm good i'll be able to
handle anything because i had
the confidence from the success that i
had and that to me is what a high value
man is these days you're confident
you're successful but you also act like
a gentleman in front of women you don't
like any guy who makes money
and is like the man and treats a woman
like [ __ ] dude you're you're missing the
whole boat here if you like the short
clip you can catch another one here or
you can catch the full episode right
here